comment en est on arrivé à un tel
désamour la présence française est
désormais pointé du doigt par une partie
du peuple malien qui reprend volontiers
les discours des autorités
ou vassaliser on peut pas transformer le
pays un esclave ça s'est terminé
il n'y a pas de zone de la palud mali ne
fait pas partie de la zone des glaces
delpy le pouvoir en place à bamako
dénonce ce qu'il considère comme une
politique impérialiste de la france et
rejette les accusations d'illégitimité
venu de paris car c'est bien après les
deux coups d'état successifs en moins
d'un an que les relations entre les deux
pays se sont dégradées le premier en
août 2020 avec le renversement du
président ibrahim boubacar kéïta le
second en mai 2021 avec la reprise en
main du pouvoir par les militaires qui
met fin au gouvernement civil de
transition qu'est ce que c'est que cette
junte qui veut rester au pouvoir encore
cinq ans après y avoir passé deux ans
après deux coups d'état successifs et
qui vient donner des leçons de
constitution des propos tenus au
lendemain de l'annoncé par le mali de
l'expulsion de l'ambassadeur de france à
bamako le point culminant de la
dégradation des relations franco
malienne notamment autour de la question
de la présence militaire française
emmanuel macron avait annoncé un
désengagement progressif en juin dernier
la présence de mercenaires russes du
groupe wagner venu se substituer aux
soldats français pour lutter contre les
groupes djihadistes à accélérer le
mouvement